[Musique]
des travaux d'envergure le samedi 5
février le travel a tort de la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines a été installé
sur les quais une nouvelle étape dans la
modernisation du site qui a que quelques
70 mille voyageurs par jour un projet
contesté à magnanville la mobilisation
se poursuit contre le projet de prison
l'établissement devrait être de 700
places et voir le jour à l'horizon 2027
une ville derrière son équipe commerce
et habitants étaient présents pour
soutenir le fc versailles lors de son
quart de finale face à bergerac la cité
royale s'est enflammé après la
qualification en demi finale de coupe de
france un jeu évidemment un meilleur jeu
de l'année c'est peut-être le titre que
décrochera api city le 24 février
prochain édité par l'entreprise
versaillaise cocktail games le jeu de
cartes le raf a sa carte à ventura et
seven wonders architectes ancien
président de tv 60,18 gérald favier a
également oeuvré pendant 22 ans en tant
qu'adjoint au maire d'elancourt vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
il laisse derrière lui de multiples
réalisations il s'était retiré de la vie
politique en 2018 pour s'occuper de sa
famille gerald de favier vient de nous
quitter à 81 ans
[Musique]
pas